la planta nuclear más grande de Europa
ha detenido su operación por completo en
el guatón la agencia Estatal ucraniana a
cargo de la planta de zaporilla informó
la madrugada del 11 de septiembre Que
desconectó el sexto y último reactor
operativo de la central luego de que
fuera reconectada a la red eléctrica de
Ucrania y los ingenieros pudieran
maniobrar mientras los combates
continuaron en el área la planta fue uno
de los primeros objetivos de Rusia Al
iniciar su invasión registrando el
primer ataque el 4 de marzo
el incendio es el resultado de los
disparos en la planta de energía nuclear
repito el incendio comenzó como
resultado de los disparos de las fuerzas
de la federación rusa en dirección a la
planta de energía
Rusia y Ucrania se vienen acusando
mutuamente de bombardear la planta con
el riesgo de provocar un desastre
radioactivo además el jefe de la planta
ha denunciado torturas asesinatos y
secuestros rusos en contra del personal
u el cual está a cargo de la operación
desde que iniciaron los enfrentamientos
organismos internacionales y expertos
han advertido sobre el peligro de la
violencia en la zona
con los bombardeos el reactor y el
sistema de enfriamiento pueden dañarse
como resultado de lo cual en principio
es posible un accidente bastante grave
no al nivel de Chernobyl sino al nivel
de fukushima
el 4 de septiembre Rafael grossi
director del oea expresó su preocupación
mediante un informe que realizó tras su
visita la planta el primero de
septiembre junto con un equipo de
expertos y exigió la creación de una
zona de seguridad para evitar un posible
desastre nuclear por su parte quien ha
pedido a los residentes de las áreas
ocupadas por Rusia alrededor de la
planta evacuar por su propia seguridad